Today, I'm starting a new series.
I'm gonna be talking about tough topics with grownups.
Today's tough topic: how to be a hero.
And today's grownup: Tim Honks!
Yes.
Excuse me, Mr. Kid President.
My name is not Tim Honks.
I have a couple questions for you.
Wow. That is a lot of questions.
This is a tough question and I got to figure this out.
How can I be a hero to somebody and what can I do today?
That's interesting.
The option is probably there, Mr. Kid President.
Now maybe, it would just be cutting somebody some slack.
They've had a tough day and they need a break...
..and you could say, "Hey it's alright, don't worry. I'm okay, I can wait."
Something else might be something bigger than that, like returning something that was lost.
I found this and rather than rifle the contents of this wallet or purse,...
...I'm gonna look at one thing in it, one thing only,...
...and that is the driver's license of who it belongs to.
And then, you'd somehow get it back to them.
Those are small little acts of heroism but they're the right things to do.